So far in this course, we've answered
the question, what is computable?
We modeled computability by Turing
machines, and showed that some problems,
like the halting problem,
cannot be computed at all.
In the next few lectures we ask,
what can we compute quickly?
Some problems,
like adding a bunch of numbers or
solving linear equations, we know
how to solve quickly on computers.
But how about playing
the perfect game of chess?
We could write a computer program that
can search the whole game tree, but that
computation won't finish in our lifetime
or even a lifetime of the universe.
Unlike computability, we don't have
clean theorems about efficient
computation, but we can explore what
we probably can't solve quickly
through what is known as
the P versus NP problem.
P represents the problems
we can solve quickly like
your GPS finding a short
route to your destination.
NP represents problems
where we can check that
a solution is correct such
as solving a Sudoku puzzle.
In this lesson we will
learn about P NP and
a role in helping us understand what we
may or may not be able to solve quickly.